You are thinking, wow this sounds tedious
and not performance conscious if exokernel has to
validate the key every time for the library to use it. Well, it depends on what
we mean by a resource. Let's look at some examples. Here is an example of a
candidate resource, a TLB entry. TLB entry is
going to establish a mapping between a virtual
page to a physical page. That mapping of the virtual page
to the physical page is done by the library. Now, once the mapping has been done
by the library, it presents the mapping to the exokernel along
with capability of the key, the encrypted key that it has for a particular
TLB entry. Exokernel validates it and puts this
mapping into the specific TLB entry of the hardware TLB. Now this is a
privileged operation. Putting an entry into the
hardware TLB, is a privileged operation. The
library operating system cannot do it by
itself, because it doesn't have the same
privilege as exokernel. And therefore, once that
capability in the form of the encrypted key
for this TLB entry is presented to
exokernel, then exokernel, on behalf of that operating
system, is putting that mapping that has
been established by the library operating system into
the specific TLB entry of the hardware TLB. Once this entry has been put into
the TLB, the process that is going to be using that virtual page, when it is
running, can use this multiple times
without exokernel intervention. So even though putting
it into the hardware TLB require the intervention of exokernel because we are
messing with hardware. Once that entry has been put in, that entry is
on behalf of this library operating system.
And processes of that library operating system,
when they are running on the CPU, can
access the TLB. And do the translation any number
of times because all of that is happening
under hardware control and exokernel, of course, is not
in the middle of any of that. So that gives you an idea of how, even though
we are seeing that in order to do certain
things in the hardware, you need exokernel help for
the library operating system. The normal use of a hardware resource is not
going to be in any way affected by the fact that exokernel is in the middle
between the hardware and the library operating
systems. Here is another example of a
candidate resource. Let's say that the operating
system wants to install a packet filter that
needs to be executed every time a network packet arrives on behalf of a
library operating system. Predicates for looking at
this incoming packet are loaded into the kernel
by the library operating system. Now, this
is a heavy-duty operation, because you're doing
it with the help of exokernel. But
once those predicates have been loaded into exokernel
by the library operating system, on
every packet arrival exokernel will automatically check
it using those predicates. So those are
examples of candidate resources that tell you
that establishing the binding may be expensive
but using the binding, once established, does
not incur the intervention by exokernal and
therefore it can happen at hardware speeds.